no matter how far I go no matter where I
go no matter what I do I don't give a
[__] if I just got a song with Lady Gaga
if she's still relevant yeah of course
she's Lady Gaga She'll always yeah yeah
I know so if I had a song with Lady Gaga
and I blew up and I had the most money
in the world
or not even that that tube or if I'm in
a car and three of my homies get smoked
right in front of me right I'm a [__]
until I go to until I'm done it's just
it's just that's it's not it's like a
fraternity like you if you're in [__]
college and you're from Alpha Phi Alpha
even when you graduate and you get your
job at the end of it my [__] is 78
years old or 80 years old you're still
gonna have your colors you're still
gonna have your logo you're still going
to pull up to those meetings so [__]
any [__] that stop banging
I really don't condone it you know like
actively like actively being in the
street and gang banging and fighting and
killing and [__] like okay [__] stop
that you for me right right grow and
evolve and metamorphosize but to just
drop your flag no yeah yeah you can't
drop your flag